by the way shoutout Salt Lake are
Mormons we had some of our biggest
laughs I think and salt yeah we've
ripped on them for [ __ ] during and
stoking and you know all the [ __ ] that
they do and they were going to have it
to avoid having sex yeah so what is
during birthing is when you like
basically you bump and grind in the
genes and it's like dry humping Urban
Dictionary describes it as spawning out
of Provo and then dudes get blue balls
it's basically situation which is like
just it's just like going to a school
dance basically do you are you edging or
are you actually full on full blast
coming I don't think the goal is to come
I think it's just like to simulate what
it's like to [ __ ] but you don't get to
do it so it's you're still edging eaters
edging over it close its first base in
Utah okay no no first base is kissing
second base is surfing and the third
base it'd be third base because homerun
is soaking I keep losing you and my
headphones
oh yeah the the splitters kind of oh
yeah she i dude [ __ ] how'd it go with
how'd it go with Janet last night bro
dude so sick she gave me over the pants
edge job it was so tight man I almost
came but then I didn't and then I wasn't
paying for eight hours afterwards yeah
so I was at Danny last night and oh my
god you know most guys they don't they
can only dar for a few minutes but he
was just oh he durf me all night I'm
talking till sermon Sunday morning and I
was just were you sore
oh yeah yeah he was wearing like 500
ones and they were like hard you know
like oh my god yeah he worked he works
like on a ranch just sounds like they
were stiff jeans you know that's so I
mean I just it's just with Josh he just
me I don't mean to I don't want to put
him on blast or anything but he
sometimes he kind of prematurely
d'oeuvres oh that mean you just d'oeuvre
too quickly no but if you don't come
then what how do you end a d'oeuvre sesh
too early no if you premature leader if
you pray
surely almost come yeah yeah that's it
if you get to the edge too quickly yeah
oh my god that's hilarious or or he just
[ __ ] up the mood like they're about to
go to during and then he just starts
like like maybe he's just on her leg
humping it she's like oh and he's like
oh I thought I was on the ass I'm sorry
that's it I do something wrong am i I
thought we were gonna derf and she's
like well I thought we were gonna dare
to until you [ __ ] off [ __ ] it up yeah
I thought we're gonna derf my vagina I
didn't know we were during my thighs you
know most guys in looking weirdo most
guys know how to derf that's right most
guys here know how to derf Dylan okay
all that all the best guys from Utah
derf me right they don't just start derf
and all dirt my kneecaps you [ __ ]
idiot so [ __ ] man howdy howdy
so I'm Sarah how'd it go with with with
Corey yesterday oh it was it was good
you know how far did you guys get well
you know me and out derf on the first
day imagine like you're hooking up with
her and you start to like kind of like
move behind and she like grabs your
heads and she's like I had a home
Haunter on the first date we're just
like what no no how you prude you prude
[ __ ] you know I'm gonna no I'm trying
to think of what the opposite of blue
balls are now I'm gonna have balls oh
hey good now I'm gonna have normal balls
yeah I wanna cut or Mormon homies to
tell us like a really good durf
experience yeah
the to tell us about a time you derf the
[ __ ] out of someone I think man I think
that's just going to the club though
yeah I mean like at school dance like
just like you know you're pumping in the
news you're gonna go back home like wow
I'm horny this is pathetic and then I
don't know either you go home with her
or you jack off and then eat a bunch of
Cheetos it's such a funny concept of the
goal of derping is to get blue balls to
achieve
blue balls yes the goal you have to just
get horny horny er yeah a year or a year
just coming here just to be in pain all
night yeah that's like a good night yeah
[ __ ] you did it man swollen bro what
happened dude was there from this [ __ ]
all night all night dude Wow oh yeah I
def the [ __ ] of her she didn't wanna
[ __ ] dude wake up yeah I think um you
know I've been I've been talking to
Molly a lot and yeah things are going
good and you know I think she's gonna
let me def do it across the room oh you
talk about Molly derf me Molly
ah dude everybody's dirt Molly he's like
what yeah dude
she's a town bicycle man everyone's got
a turf everyone gets a dirt man
she's like a football field everybody's
running down that dirt you know what I'm
saying
it's like Molly she's a [ __ ] she's
lobster and steak man we call her surf
and turf oh man oh man yeah dude we call
her Venice Beach dog dirt sup Thomas
[ __ ] yeah birthing everything dude
that's really funny has a great word
everything sis I mean I said it on stage
I'll say it again when I was like y'all
are weird you do that you're like it's
just such a foreign concept to me to
like intentionally like grind in jeans
or pants it's hilarious I mean you know
maybe in the moderate maybe that's what
it was before maybe in the modern era
you know it's like wearing Lululemon's
and basketball shorts you know maybe
they're like you know maybe it gets
really bare-bones so it gets real close
yeah you know maybe during is evolved
and we're just in the dark you know what
stoking is yeah yeah but for the soaking
is you put it in you actually put it in
and just don't but then you just leave
it so you don't thrust it all you would
just stay perfectly still there's no
motion there is no way yeah I don't know
how I'd be like okay okay okay okay okay
here we go
and oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] did you just oh whoa
are you saying you're blasting officers
yeah I would do it if you haven't had
sex or jacked off I don't actually know
you probably whack it a ton but if
you've never [ __ ] for years and years
and then you get that feeling of vagina
oh yeah yeah it definitely it was the
first time you had sex oh yeah it was
over in 15 second it was over
yeah dunzo yeah i spunked I just
instantly yeah okay we're just gonna
we're just gonna soak ten seconds that's
all you get okay so ten second okay okay
that's it so fine it's like a dirty pan
you know you gotta soak it it just
letting like the juices like just soak
into your dick until it gets soft again
and then you take it out nothing [ __ ]
juice gives you like a beard makes you
taller
okay okay okay here we go ten seconds
all right
why the [ __ ] oh god I just
sinned were you not in me did you
seriously just not in me I thought we
were soaking we have to get married now
and we are going to raise this child
together like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we should
have just dirt instead oh [ __ ] man
that's our new [ __ ] brand your fatty
your daddy's yeah bro where your derf
daddy's we're your derf daddy's flex
flex
bangs I'm trying to flex not trying to
flex take your vision notion break
that's not a flex